so the other day I was talking to a
friend of mine about an acquaintance
that we know when she said such a slut
and it made me wonder you know who
exactly is a slut and what makes you one
so I turned to my very wise friend the
internet slut o slatton Slatter Shh I'm
defining things for you slut off Latin
is a term applied to an individual who
is sexually promiscuous or who is
considered to have loose sexual morals
the accepted adaptive meaning is a
sexually promiscuous woman or a woman of
low or loose character the term is
generally pejorative and is most often
used as an insult
what the hell's a slattern but even that
definition was confusing to me because
how the hell does one define loose
sexual morals so I asked my usually not
so helpful friends Yahoo Answers I know
I know it means a person who has no no
morals it's about girls who put out all
the time someone who changes their moral
code to accommodate other people usually
at a detriment to themselves exempli
gratia someone who disrespects themself
enough to sleep around but if a slut is
someone who sleeps around at the
detriment to themselves then doesn't
that mean that the only person who can
accurately judge whether or not someone
is a slut is the potential slut
because from an outside point of view we
don't really know if you're sleeping
around because you want to because
you're meeting a fuck ton of often
people or because you're in a lot of
pain and that's the only way you know
how to ease it so who is a slut that's
why we're all here and that's why we
clicked on the video well through my
super reliable internet research I have
found that a slut can only be defined by
each of us in self reflection of the
motivations of our sexual actions but
even more importantly why do we call
each other sluts
anyway sex is the one driving force that
keeps our species in existence and when
we're young we're all a little horn
anyway why shame each other over basic
desires when our hormones are at their
peak we don't think twice about grinding
and dry humping inanimate objects like
our couches so that's a pretty strong
shit take slut out of your vocabulary
because you don't have the right to
judge anyone's sexual activity except
your own stay off and Gotham okay I hope
I wasn't focused